emilie alors on l'a dit dans votre lit
énormément d'anecdotes d'histoires que
vous avez pu vivre si vous deviez en
garder qu'une seule la plus drôle la
plus improbable
alors si je devais en garder qu'une
seule je serais bien embêté mais c'est
merci on parle le plus c'est un monsieur
qui était arrivé sur il y avait eu un
terrible incendie
on est au milieu de la nuit un couple
est mort dans l'incendié de sa maison
alors je suis désolé je casse l'ambiance
mais dans mes histoires il ya toujours
quelqu'un qui meurt donc les pompes
funèbres arrive pour évacuer les corps
les deux personnes sont sont morts
décédés brûlées vives et le frère du
monsieur le frère du monsieur arrive
appelé par la police donc il est 4
heures du matin vous imaginez la scène
les pompiers étaient de la même tendance
fumer est allé gendarmes partout voilà
il monsieur vient voir demande comment
ça se passe
les gendarmes renvoie vers les pompes
funèbres et donc qu'ils arriveront
funèbre il dit bon bah je passerai vous
voir demain matin pour régler les
formalités ce sera une crémation mais
vous fera un prix parce que le travail
est déjà bien entamée du coup vous avez
fait le prix ou pas c'est bon c'est pas
moi qui l'ait reçue le matin est d'avoir
ce
c'est en même temps totalement faux oui
mais si vous saviez en fait les pompes
funèbres
c'est les cérémonies les obsèques etc
j'ai coutume de dire c'est comme un
concert de heavy metal en fait on pousse
le bouton de l'ampli à fond et on met
les sentiments donc les gens sont
poussés dans leurs derniers
retranchements et c'est là où on peut
voir certaines qui fait les gens se
révèlent ouais il ya des ja des [ __ ]
qui deviennent qui s'avèrent être des
gens merveilleux et puis des gens qu'on
croyait merveilleux qui irait qui enlève
le mans voilà un peu donc donc en fait
vous vivez dans un livre de balzac et
c'est la nature humaine tout le temps
ouais enfin gea pas me comparer à
molsheim
moi j'étais fou rire nerveux quand je
vois des morts enfin bon bref cela dit
elle a raison parce que c'est vrai il ya
beaucoup de fous rires aux enterrements
ah ouais moi scénario non mais c'est
normal on ne sait pas on sait pas c'est
pas une réaction normale et c'est une
réaction qui déclenche qui pousse le
bouton détrônant à fond donc forcément
on ne sait pas toujours comment réagir
et on a t on est sur pilotage
automatique sur beaucoup de choses
les fous rires nerveux c'est ni plus ni
moins que ça si quelqu'un éclate de rire
à un enterrement lui envoyer passé oui
oui je vais le curseur est trés haut
comme alors on doit se consoler sa part
alors j'ai cru comprendre que là vous
étiez marier mais avant cela
donc vous êtes croque mort qu'est ce que
vous dites un rendez vous galant
j'imagine que vous dit pas tout de suite
ça lui alors moi oui je m'occupe des
morts non mais justement j'ai une
anecdote là dessus il ya plusieurs
années
j'étais jeune et beau à l'époque c'est
toujours vous êtes uniquement à oui je
suis je suis je suis moins jeunes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il avait rencontré on était dans un café
j'avais rencontré une jeune femme ça se
passait bien on discute on discute et
puis au bout d'un moment elle me demande
qu'est ce que je fais qu'est ce que je
fais dans la vie je dis pas je
travaillais au conflit nombre là elle se
faire un beau fixe comme ça elle se lève
elle prend son sac son manteau elle se
barre non mais non vous fait quoi
ouais ouais ça fait au bas ça fait canal
+ 14 15 ans maintenant j'ai jamais revu
il est rien mais ben en fait j'aurais
bien aimé ne serait-ce qu'à voir une
explication mais même pas non séparé à
mon avis c'est votre métier
j'espère alors pour terminer de juste
une petite dernière question est ce que
ce métier-là fait que vous envisagez
votre vie la vie différemment vous
disant plaçons je sais où je vais finir
donc autant m'amuser autant avoir cet
humour comme la gale et voilà autant
elles font penser ça vous a changé ce
métier disons que oui ça m'a changé dans
le sens où
je prends beaucoup moins de choses au
sérieux finalement bien sûr ces voix là
quand je vois des gens qui se prennent
la tête pour des bêtises vous dit rien
n'est grave sauf la mort voile et voile
alors merci infiniment d urbanisme